everyone welcome to your daily equation  today I do not have a new episode for  you but I will pick it up tomorrow with  a live session and like last week if you  keep on asking questions that I will do  my best to keep on answering them in the  meantime you might enjoy checking out  this video the link below it's an  appearance I had on The Late Show  Stephen Colbert where we discussed the  general theory of relativity we did a  couple of experiments and at the end  Stephen asked me a surprise question  that got us a little bit into the  mathematics of the general theory of  relativity I think it'll have fun  watching it until tomorrow  take care